der beste experte ich möchte mich ein
bisschen in diesem video mit einem thema
beschäftigen was euro in letzter zeit
sehr viel beschäftigt hatte ich
wahrscheinlich jetzt vor dem hintergrund
des mcdonalds burger bertels werden wir
heute pesto testen jetzt wir haben drei
verschiedene sorgen besorgt wir haben
hier unseren unabhängigen pesto tester
vor ort eine langjährige ausbildung
durchgemacht hatte ich im pesto testen
könnte gerade noch ihre qualifikation
auf zehn vielleicht ja ich bin
talentiert ich bin nicht nur vom sexy
sexy
alles sei okay
wie verändert jetzt kommt man ja das
fertigen und binden dem dieses komische
stück stoff was ich da im kopf habe um
damit er sich nicht vom eindruck ihre
teams um optischen zweiten mal hier über
augen sodass das pesto nicht anschauen
ihr seht ihr da haben wir drei sorten
besten film
ich weiß nicht ob du deine gesehen sind
wunder aufgeräumt diese tisch ist
du musst bisschen überraschen ich wie
ich bin schon zweifel comeback ist zu
krank
ich bin ich bin ich unserem glauben
sonst habe ich meine ein test der
irgendwann willst du willst du mit dem
weg mit dem motto lass dir zeit lasst
ihr seid schmeckt also was musik braucht
er ist lustig ja irgendwie im abgang so
ein bisschen nach nach mango ich hab
euch mal ein gedicht was er wirklich
drin ist in diesem test schmeckt für
mich jetzt ein bisschen genauso wie das
andere nach links ein bisschen zu
fruchtig nein
doch ich finde zu gast beim pesto sonst
machen fest so ist ein richtiges ist ja
aus früchten gemacht weil tomaten sind
kein obst glaube ich und
und der seitlichen zu frank geben
das dritte paket ist eine sache ist aus
der ersten runde
aber jetzt dass du das dritte fest und
karnickel kleines dem kritischen urteil
des des testers standhalten kann
vor den autos geschmacksknospen die
kritik der beste experte zum beispiel
raus geht es nach mal richtiges sms
interessanterweise hat der proteste alle
drei sorten von pesto für zu fruchtig
befunden
es ist mir unerklärlich ehrlich gesagt
also wir haben ja einmal oliven haben
wir keine ahnung was der faktor spaß
also versuchte ich habe das geschmeckt
das war mir zu frucht die kloster das
ist kein richtiges paroli und die
galaxie mambo hier drüben also leute von
mcdonald's wenn ihr das nächste mal ein
pastor aus bringt dann macht's einfach
nicht so fruchtig
denn wenn sogar lachs schon fertig ist
dann muss ich wirklich das 1